[Musique]
merci l'
étranger
a démontré sa capacité à
cibler et à modifier de manière autonome l'orbite
d'un objet céleste. L'impact de Dart
sur l'astéroïde dimorphe a été
confirmé à 19 h 14, heure de l'Est, lorsque
le centre d'opérations de la mission Dart ici
à APL a perdu le signal avec le
maintenant, un vaisseau spatial perd normalement le signal d'un
vaisseau spatial est une très mauvaise chose, mais dans
ce cas, c'était le résultat idéal.
[Musique étrangère]
nous allons voir ces données
descendre bientôt dans les prochains jours,
puis au cours des deux prochains  mois, nous
allons voir plus d'informations de la part de l'
équipe d'enquête sur le changement de période que
nous avons réellement effectué parce que c'est notre
objectif numéro deux. Le premier était de frapper l'
astéroïde, ce que nous avons fait, mais maintenant le numéro
deux est vraiment de mesurer ce changement de période
et de le caractériser.  combien d'éjectas nous avons
réellement émis de
[Musique] étrangère,
pour autant que nous puissions en juger, notre premier
test de défense planétaire a été un succès et
je pense que nous pouvons collaborer là-dessus, tout le monde,
alors ouais, eh bien, je euh ouais, je pense que
les Terriens devraient mieux dormir et
certainement je le ferai ouais